[Music]
my dad is Robert Earhart deaf and my
mom's name is Susan Colleen Cobb I know
that my dad was born into money and I
think that it was a hard thing for my
dad's mother to accept like my mom right
away she didn't come from money my whole
life all I've ever heard is that my mom
was like grew up super poor and on the
rough side of town I don't think it was
the easiest upbringing but my mom is a
Spitfire and I think she wanted better
you know and she fought for it and she
worked hard I think my dad coming from a
more prominent family we've always been
told more stories and I think you know
the alternative for my mom's side was
just like a big loss of information
there and all the information that we
get from them is like they're like
country people down home and that's all
we know so it's that's fine but it'd be
nice to know that there's more and to
like dive deeper into that my mom's
mother is Amy slimmer and my mom's
father is Samuel Cobb I don't know about
Peppa Sam he died when I was really
little and I believe my mom's mother was
born in Cameron Texas which is a real
real small town my parents always told
my sister and I that we were a Heinz 57
just we were like made up of a bunch of
different stuff so like Dutch and
Scottish and Irish and German I think
Lucas would not accept that he'd be like
what do you mean more ketchup inside I
want to tell him where I came from and
what he's made up of and he'll get to
share that with his family down the line
which is just an amazing like trickle
effect like it's a real gift
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]